first this year's Nobel Prize for
chemistry will be shared by three
scientists Morton meldau from Denmark
and two Americans Carolyn bertotsi and
Barry sharpless they have been
recognized for the development of
bio-orthogonal chemistry and click
chemistry which involves attaching
molecules together to create
sharpless only the fifth person ever to
receive a second Nobel Prize
now here's what the chair of the Nobel
committee for chemistry Johan aquist had
to say
click chemistry is almost almost like it
sounds
it's all about snapping molecules
together
imagine that you could attach small
chemical buckles to different types of
building blocks
then you could link these buckles
together and produce molecules of
Greater complexity and variation
now with me in the studio is Leah
Albright from our science department to
break it all down
click chemistry first of all it very
much sounds like Lego to me so what what
does it mean it does sound like Lego to
me as well and actually that was the
picture I first had in mind it does
sound like a game and it kind of is
because it's it really yeah imagine Lego
cubes you have a yellow one you have a
blue one and a green one and you can
click them easily together and build
something new out of it right a house or
whatever you want and that's a click
chemistry with molecules in in very tiny
Dimensions so the Lego cubes are
molecules and you can again put or take
different molecules and click them
easily together so the new thing now is
that they found the the click like the
buckles as we just heard and that was
yeah that was the new discovery they
made and which made it easy now to to
have new buildings new molecular
buildings and our
um yeah in chemistry as a tall as a
whole but also in our bodies and our
living cells even okay that sounds
exciting tell us a bit more about the
the three laureates and their research
well very sharpless he was the first to
discover the concept of Click chemistry
so he had the idea that well maybe we
could take these two molecules and kind
of Click them have an easy way to put
them together
um and this this idea went all over the
chemistry world it was really huge and
many people then started to think about
applications and to how to put this into
practice so that's where Martin meldel
came in and he found the first reaction
where that actually occurred be could be
applied where he could yeah make
molecules yeah exactly make molecules
click together and he used copper as a
buckle now copper is a metal and if we
look in our bodies Metals too much too
many metals are not really good and they
are too much metal especially too much
copper
so the question came up how can we use
Clear chemistry in our cells and our
bodies and that's where Carolyn batozi
came in and she used sugars or like a
sugar complex as buckles and now made it
also possible to to click to get the
molecules in our own body in living
cells
now how does all of this affect our
lives I mean can I soon uh can we sort
of click together a new I don't know
kidney for me
well a kidney yeah I think that that's
another
um part of research then but
um the good thing about collecting
molecules together is that you can also
click something a shiny molecule onto
another molecule on our body so you can
make things shine you can make things
see in our body and that's how you can
track for example where processes take
place where diseases develop where drugs
are are delivered in our body if they go
to the wrong place or to the right place
so it really helped us in pharmaceutical
development it helped us in yeah in
making new drugs but also in materials
research how to make more robust new
materials which is of course
um yeah kind of needed in these times of
climate change and everything else but I
think the pharmaceutical
um yeah things have really that's really
the new thing and that's also what what
the Laureate Karen batozi mentioned in
her in her speech after uh after she was
announced the winner of this Nobel Prize
from our science department thank you
very much Leah for shining some light on
to click chemistry